he is Ernie Johnson how are you EJ rich
I'm doing great how are you I'm hanging
in there
thank you really appreciate you calling
in yeah how are things out there it's
kind of crazy I'm not gonna lie to you
it's got a little bit of an apocalyptic
feel to it honest where you never know
where things might turn but it is just
the latest example of how I started the
show of how incredible our first
responders are and how you know when we
need them they're right there and I put
my head on the pillow last night to be
very I couldn't believe I can't believe
what I'm seeing on online and on the
news and you know and with people
driving to work and seeing entire
hillsides on fire in that day and I
think Man Alive it's just horrible ya
know I told my kids that I had snow days
when when I was a kid now that they're
on fire days today oh I wish they could
go out and do a snow angel and snow
instead of ash but uh it's horrible to
see thanks well look at some prayers for
all you guys out there thanks Arnie sure
I really appreciate that I was talking
about this on the show yesterday it is
funny how we're not wondering where
LeBrons playing next year anymore that's
gone it's amazing what winds do isn't it
right yeah I mean and we'll probably
have this conversation on the air
tonight too because I know that when
Charles was talking about oh you know
Cleveland it's not going to get better
they're just old and that kind of thing
and now they're just just on a on a
13-game roll but it's uh yeah you know
how that works if you know you lose two
or three in a row and suddenly it's all
what's wrong and here's the team gonna
implode and that kind of thing and then
all of a sudden it's okay things are
okay in Cleveland okay next next topic
right and because he's it just is
remarkable how well LeBron is playing at
that in his advancing years I guess and
then IT comes back at some point you
know what that's gonna be like too rich
it's gonna be like a trade deadline move
Yeah right no it's gonna be like you're
gonna add us this huge piece where
people said well how did they get him at
the trade deadline and it's been it's
going to be well he's now he's healthy
and and so what are we gonna see from
Cleveland when when he gets out there
that's you know that's one of those
things that you know it's it's a great
addition
once once the team is already rolling
yeah I know I don't feel that work and I
know Harden again who's on tonight on
TNT taking on taking on the Jazz he's in
the he's in the MVP mix for sure yeah
but it's fun how right now it does look
like it's shaping up about LeBron versus
Kyrie and also for the conference right
now I would say that too in the East
right now I mean that's those are the
two teams everybody else is pretty even
I mean Toronto's in there but but
everybody else even Philadelphia is
playing well we'll see them tonight
against the Lakers and and we're going
to see a bunch of good good looking
rookies tonight on TNT and not not to
turn this into a promotion for our know
better but I mean no I mean you when you
look at Ben Simmons on the Philadelphia
side you look at Kyle Kuzma and
obviously it's been a rough go for
Alonso but the second game has got a guy
that nobody's talking about Donovan
Mitchell for Utah who's had an
unbelievable rookie season so far so
yeah good stuff tonight
yeah and embiid is turning into one of
my favorite players to watch not just
because of what he does on the court but
just you know I just love following his
exploits it's it really just like
floating around with Joel embiid on his
twitter feed just seen that picture of
him next to next to the MVP himself from
the Houston Astros you know just seeing
him versus Jose Altuve where he comes up
to his knee next to JJ Watt from the
Sports Illustrated event the other night
that was just I just love watching him
just be you know what you know what what
it what it strikes me as is a guy who's
finally able to play after all the
uncertainty and and people wonder Jesus
is his career in jeopardy is he ever
going to play and he's just getting
great joy out of the sport it's almost
it's almost like the first and second
year of yasiel puig you know where you
just you love the joy and even his
teammates were talking about the joy he
gets out of play in the game and and to
me it's watching embiid now is doing
what he loves to do and just enjoying
every minute of it and and and really
diving into the social aspect and
everything else no he's been he's been
fun to watch man and he's got all the
skills to match it Ernie Johnson
here on the Rich Eisen show so walk me
through a meeting with you guys because
I know what my meetings like with
Marshall and Michael Irvin and and Kurt
Warner and mooch
do you guys even have a meeting before a
show or you just like what do you speak
what you speak of is is very foreign to
me rich because we don't have that I
mean it and that's really the only show
I've ever been on that that is it is
like that because everything else that
you do you have you know when we're
doing baseball playoff so there's
breakfast meetings before we do the
games and and and Ronnie darling is
there with me and and and with with this
group it's it's not the way it is at all
I mean I'm in the meeting with the
producer and with you know all the
technical guys and and and the stat guys
and graphics and everything but no we
don't you know Shaq and Charles and
Kenny aren't there and it's not that
they are invited and they made it
abundantly clear that you know being at
the studio for hours in advance is not
going to work and so so though know we
and we want to hit them you know I we
want to hit them with stuff that that is
fresh to them sugar so that we're not
you know rehearsing segments or any of
that kind of thing and and the guys keep
up with the league enough that anything
you can throw out they're gonna they're
gonna have an opinion on and so so
that's the way it works and and but it's
it's totally different from any other
show out there I think I think most most
of the time all the talent is in there
but not here and in fact the first time
we did March Madness with the guys at
CBS one of the CBS producers in the
studio all that yeah we're on the area
we're gonna hit the air at 12:30 you
know with our first pregame you know we
got four networks you know who are gonna
be working on this and and so we'll meet
it will meet at 11 o'clock and Charles
like oh what meet at 11 o'clock no
that's not going to happen but he he has
relented to it too enough that you know
a half hour or 45 minutes before we go
on the air we are actually all together
at a at a March Madness meeting but
that's the only time
about to say when you go when you go to
another network and partner up like that
obviously Thursday Night Football I've
had you know I've been partnered up with
various networks over the years and then
they sometimes see how we do it it's so
the system sometimes that's exactly the
way it was and and and really that
that's one of the things about the
marriage between CBS and Turner for
March Madness that it has been kind of
fun to watch because I think we've
incorporated elements of both styles of
the way we like to do things in the way
CBS has typically done things in the in
the past and and and they've done such a
great job with March Madness through the
years that you don't want to really mess
with that formula but when we came in
with this with the four networks and and
and the way our guys best operate and in
and then even translate it into the
shows where you know they'd say well
let's do this and this and this and I
said well I don't know if we're going to
get all that because when we go to this
place these guys may really run with
that until we're out of time so it was
it's been a great thing to watch how
they've you know CBS has kind of said
you know okay we we understand how you
do things and and the success that
you've had on the NBA side you know
let's kind of incorporate the two
certainly if Charles just says I'm not
showing to a meeting it sounds like
sometimes Dion will just say I'm not
rehearsing we're just not going to do
that okay
whatever gonna make the show better I
mean that's that's the way we've always
viewed it that you know if we don't want
our show to come off as okay this is the
fourth time they've run through this you
know in Shaq's gonna say this and Kenny
or laugh at this and Charles will say
this and I'll throw a break you know
it's it's let's just see what happens
well I know that you don't want it to be
just there's no way it could be that way
it's just and it's just so great to
watch it and just give it an idea of how
you make it look like it's all planned
too it's you make it you make it all
work Ernie it doesn't work without you
it doesn't and I can't I have no problem
I don't know you you're you're kind of
like that guy who I work with you know
that hasn't made the Hall of Fame yet
and I always say he's a future
hall-of-famer and they look at me like
don't say that you kind of like you
can't you're kind of like that guy when
I when I
tell you how great you are that you know
you remind me of those guys you're very
kind but let's let's move on well I
guess we're done then no no no seriously
I'm looking forward to seeing tonight's
double dip I'll have it on along with
the Falcons and Saints wear you know but
it's gonna be interesting night they're
in Atlanta
yeah they're huge it's a huge game for
the Falcons and I think the last one of
the last times I was on the show with
you yeah you were asking about the
Patriots going undefeated and I said no
13 and 3 so I'm it I'm still it you know
I'm in the I'm in the ballpark right now
all right
yeah I mean what are they tended to they
are 10 and 2 that means they gotta lose
one more maybe it's the Steelers could
be that it could be 13 and 3 and and
that was a prediction a blind prediction
not looking at at the schedule at all
just kind of that's kind of take enough
wild guesses they had 13 and 3 no I'm
working now you are you I'm sure you
have you and Musburger talk about how it
all works out behind the scenes I'm sure
are you gonna watch my dogs we're near
when they go out there to the Rose Bowl
I'm bringing the family we're going
we're thats gonna be great
Ernie hey look I wish I could have seen
you in person next time and I always
love having you on thanks for calling in
I would love to do it too have a great
one rich always a good talking thanks
you got it that's Ernie Johnson
so Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience